ciao ragazzi io vi chiedo perdono perché
un anno fa avevo promesso che sarei
tornato alla fine non ho postato più
nulla ma sono tornato
ok e per farlo deciso di raccontarvi in
questo video magari delle cose che non
sapete di me e ho pensato anche per
rimanere così al passo coi tempi di di
fare un elenco delle dieci cose che mi
piacciono e delle dieci che non mi
piacciono
partiamo subito allora le cose che mi
piacciono sono le ciliegie il sushi
libri il rumore della pioggia e il cazzo
londra di andy le stelle i murales a
indovinelli poi le cose invece che non
mi piacciono sono il caldo le scale la
febbre i formaggi stagionati la [ __ ]
char izard lo spam
il calcio poi altro c'è le ingiustizie e
assieme a lei marsupi e questo era il
mio video spero che vi sia piaciuto e
naturalmente fatemi sapere nei commenti
qui sotto cos'è che vi piace e cos'è che
non vi piace
ok ci vediamo al prossimo video ciao
scusate ragazzi si scusa è uno serio e
sono tornato